the jurogan experience i do have an
opinion on algorithms and i do have an
opinion on what it does do to young
girls self-esteem and
you have teenage daughters yes i i just
think it mean and young girls are a
point of focus for
why their point of focus more than young
boys i'm not entirely sure i guess it
has to do with their emotional makeup
and and uh there's higher risk of
self-harm due to social media and
jonathan hate talked about that in his
book the coddling of the american mind
um it's it's very clear that it's very
damaging and i my kids uh you know my 13
year old does
have like interactions with their
friends and i do see how they bully each
other and talk about each other and
it's they get so angry and mad at each
other
um
it is a factor but it's an a it's an
algorithm issue right
it's there's multiple things here so the
first thing is um just to kind of set
the stage a little bit uh
i always use eo wilson the
sociobiologist who who uh
sort of defined what what the problem
statement for humanity is he said the
fundamental problem of humanity is we
have paleolithic emotions and brains
like easy brains that are hackable for
magicians we have medieval institutions
you know government that's not really
good at seeing the latest tech whether
it was railroads or now social media or
ai or deep fakes or whatever's coming
next and then we have god-like
technology so we have paleolithic
emotions medieval institutions
god-like technology
you combine that fact that's the
fundamental problem statement how do we
wield the power of god's without the
love prudence and wisdom of god there's
actually something that daniel taught me
and
then you add to that the race to the
bottom of the brainstem for attention
what is their business model just to
review the basics everybody knows this
now but it's it's engagement it's like
how do i get that attention at all costs
yeah so algorithms is one piece of that
meaning um when you're on a news feed
like i don't want to just show you any
news i want to show you the most viral
engaging like longest argumentative
comment threads news right so that's
like pointing a trillion dollar market
cap ai at your brain saying i'm going to
show you the next perfect boogeyman for
your nervous system the thing that's
going to make you upset angry whether
it's masks vaccines francis haugen
whatever the thing is it will just drive
that over and over again and then repeat
that thing and that's one of the the
tools in the arsenal to get attention is
that the algorithms another one is
technology making design decisions like
how do we inflate people's sense of uh
beautification filters in fact just
recently since we talked last time um i
think it's a mit tech review article
showing that um they're all they're all
competing first of all to like inflate
your sense of beauty so they're doing
the the i think you've definitely the
filter
people know this stuff it's very obvious
but they're competing for who can give
you a nicer filter right and then now
instead of waiting for you to actually
add one tick tock was actually found to
actually do like a two percent like just
bare beautification filter on the no
filter mode because the thing is once
they do that the other guys have to do
it too
so i just want to name that all of this
is taking place in this race to capture
human attention because if i don't do it
the other guy will and then it's
happening with design decisions like the
beautification filters and like the
follow you and if you follow me i'll
follow you back and the like button and
check pulled refresh the dopamine stuff
that's all design then there's the
algorithms which is i'm pointing a thing
at your brain to figure out what how can
i show you an infinite feed that just
maximally enrages you and we should talk
about that because that thing drives
polarization which breaks democracy but
that's a that's a we can get into that
oh daniel let's bring you in here so how
did you guys uh meet and
how did this sort of
dynamic duo come about
yeah i was working on studying kind of
catastrophic risks writ large you've had
people on the show talking about risks
associated with ai and with crispr and
genetic engineering and with climate
change and environmental issues pull up
to the microphone there and there you go
escalation pathways to war and all these
kinds of things and basically how can
hit the fan right
and i think it's a
pretty common question of like how long
do we have on which of these and are we
doing a good job of tending to them so
that we get to solve the rest of them
and then for me it was there were so
many of them what was in common driving
them are there any kind of like societal
generator functions of all the
catastrophic risks that we can address
with to make a more
resilient civilization writ large
tristan was working on the social media
issues and
when you had eric on he talked about the
twin nuclei problem of
atomic energy and kind of genetic
engineering and basically saying these
are extremely
powerful technologies that we don't have
the wisdom to steward that power well
well in addition to that is all things
computation does right there's a few
other major categories and computation
has the ability to as as you mentioned
with facebook get to billions of people
in a very very short period of time
compared to how quickly the railroads
expanded or any other type of tech get
to a billion people billion users which
they did in like a few years versus
before that it took software companies
like microsoft even longer than that
before that took railroads even longer
than that so the power of this tech is
you can compress the timeline so you're
getting you know a scale of a billion
people you're impacting a billion people
in deeper ways much faster which means
that if you're blind to something if you
don't know what you might be doing the
consequences show up faster than you can
actually remediate them when we say
exponential tech we mean a number of
things we mean tech that makes more
powerful versions of itself so i can use
computer chips to model how to make
better computer chips and then those
better computer chips can recursively do
that we also mean exponential speed of
impact exponential scale of impact
exponentially
more capital returns exponentially uh
smaller numbers of people capable of
achieving a scale of impact and so when
he's mentioning god-like powers and kind
of medieval institutions
the speed at which our tech is having
influences in the world and not just
first order influences the obvious stuff
but the second and third order ones
facebook isn't trying to polarize the
population it's an externality it's a
side effect of the thing they're trying
to do which is to optimize ad revenue
but the speed at which new technologies
are having effects on the world and the
total amount of consequence is way
faster than regulation can keep up with
and regulation and just by that alone we
should be skeptical of any government's
ability to regulate something that's
moving faster than it faster than it can
appraise of what the hell is even
happening in the first place so not only
that you need someone who really
understands the technology and you're
not going to get that from elected
officials you're going to need someone
who's working on it and has a
comprehensive understanding
of how the stuff works how it's
engineered where it goes
you're i mean i'm skeptical of the
government being able to regulate almost
everything